Have you ever stopped to think
about those invisible lines we
draw in society?
Ones between like freedom and
safety.
Exactly that balance, or maybe
that tension between 1:00 and
complete freedom and needing,
well, security.
It plays out everywhere.
It really does in our own lives,
our towns, even how we think
about the country.
So today, that's what we're
doing, a deep dive into that
specific dilemma, this constant
push and pull right between 1:00
and Comfort, security and the
other side.
Raw freedom, uncurated freedom,
with all the risks that come
with it.
It's messy.
Absolutely messy, and it's a
fundamental question really.
More than just politics.
Yeah.
It's about what we as humans
actually value.
What are you willing to give up
for protection?
To help us explore this, we're
digging into this really
compelling piece.
It's called Live Free or Zoo
America's Alphaville choice.
Like Chris Abraham.
And it's not just dry facts,
it's almost allegorical uses,
these really vivid comparisons,
cultural references.
It genuinely makes you see
things differently.
Yeah, it sticks with you.
So our mission today for you,
our listener, is to get a
richer, maybe more nuanced grasp
of this core dilemma.
It feels very American, but
maybe it's universal.
Could be, and hopefully by the
end you'll be thinking about
your own stance in this, what
the article calls the Alphaville
choice.
Right.
Do you lean towards that
perfectly managed life, or does
that call of the wild, the
unpredictable, resonate more?
Let's let's unpack it.
So where does this whole thing
start?
Interestingly, it kicks off with
something pretty mundane, a
meme.
Right, one of those quick
shareable images.
This one was don't California my
South Carolina.
You've probably seen stuff like
it.
It wasn't just a slogan, though,
it was making an argument
visually.
Yeah, it was deceptively simple,
like a split screen.
South Carolina on one side,
California on the other.
And then stats underneath.
Exactly.
Homicide rates, GDP, life
expectancy just laid out and
well on paper.
California look better.
By most of those metrics, yeah,
Longer lives, higher incomes,
lower crime rates.
Statistically, it seemed like
the clear winner, Gleaming
almost.
And South Carolina.
Presented as ragged, poorer,
less protected, statistically
riskier, you know, more likely
to face violence, shorter
lifespan.
A stark contrast.
But then you have that phrase.
Don't California my South
Carolina.
It sounds kind.
Of like a cheap bumper sticker?
Yeah, easy to dismiss.
But the article argues there's
something much deeper going on
there beneath the surface.
Precisely.
It taps into this profoundly
old, really vital question for
any free people, a question
debated for centuries, which is
it boils down to this.
Would you rather live well fed,
maybe longer, definitely safer
inside what the article calls a
well built enclosure like a
sanctuary, OK.
Or would you consciously risk a
shorter life, maybe a harsher
one, more dangerous, just for
the chance to quote, stay wild
enough to matter.
Wow.
That's that's a heavy choice.
It's not just about where you
live.
Not at all.
It's philosophical.
It's about your whole
orientation to the world,
security versus self
determination.
It frames the whole dilemma
really well.
OK, so that brings us right to
this concept the article uses is
the good zoo.
If we're talking enclosures,
what does a good zoo actually
mean here?
Yeah, it's a striking term, and
the definition is interesting
because it's not about, like,
trickery, the article says.
A good zoo works.
It's effective.
Effective how?
It genuinely keeps the animals
or people in this metaphor alive
longer than they might survive
in the wild.
It feeds them reliably shelters
them from predators, Real or
metaphorical.
OK.
Basic needs met, but there's
more.
Yes, and this is the crucial
part.
It surrounds them with enough
illusions of freedom that the
fence fades into the landscape.
So the control isn't obvious.
It feels natural.
Exactly.
The boundaries are soft, maybe
even invisible.
They just become part of the
background.
It's control that feels like
comfort, not confinement.
And the source gives a real
world example of this good zoo,
right points to a specific
state.
It does.
It positions California as
America's best Zoo suggests.
California has spent like over a
century perfecting this this art
of curating risk.
Curating risk.
That's a really interesting
phrase.
What does that mean?
Not eliminating risk, but
managing it.
Precisely.
You can't eliminate risk
entirely, right?
Life doesn't work that way, but
you can manage it, shape it,
control the parameters, make
sure risks are predictable,
contained.
So life becomes safer, more
predictable.
Yes, but maybe at the expense of
those really spontaneous high
Stace experiences, the truly
wild moments that's.
Yeah, that's a powerful idea.
Maybe a bit unsettling.
So how?
How did California, according to
the article, achieve this
curated state?
What's the history?
It's a long progression over a
century.
The article traces it back to
the early progressive
performers, like in the 1910s.
OK.
The progressives, what do they
do?
They believe in rational
planning, scientific expertise
to improve society.
So they laid groundwork for more
state intervention, more
regulation, public health, urban
planning, resource management.
Like setting up state parks?
Early environmental rules.
Exactly.
Early attempts to create a more
ordered, safer environment,
mitigating disease, ensuring
sanitation, building
infrastructure.
Then what came next?
Well, jump forward to the mid
century, post World War 2, the
suburban dream.
Levittown and all that.
Right Explosive growth, but also
this conscious effort to create
ordered, predictable
communities, Strict zoning,
homeowners associations, planned
roads, schools, parks.
Insulating families from chaos,
from the city, from the wild.
Pretty much designing
communities to buffer residents
from the darkness outside the
fence, as the article puts it.
Trading some individual autonomy
for collective predictability,
safety and sameness, maybe?
And today, how has it evolved?
Today it's the sophisticated
mix, robust welfare, safety
Nets, right to catch people,
comprehensive climate codes.
Think building regulations for
earthquakes, wildfires, trying
to mitigate environmental
threats.
Protecting property lives.
Yeah.
And even things like pilot
programs for universal basic
income, trying to provide that
fundamental economic security.
It all sounds aimed at
minimizing fear, minimizing
risk.
That's the consistent promise,
yeah.
Through all these stages, no one
needs to fear the darkness
outside the fence.
An implicit agreement the state
the system will provide a buffer
against hardship, disaster,
uncertainty.
It sounds incredibly appealing.
I mean, who wouldn't want less
fear, more security?
On the surface, absolutely, but
the article is very clear
there's a trade off.
It's not free.
OK, so what's the cost?
What do you give up for that
managed existence, that spot in
the good zoo?
This is where the metaphor
really bites.
The cost is accepted, lifting
fewer claws, fewer teeth, fewer
chances to fail so completely
that you become a threat to the
others inside.
Fewer claws, fewer teeth
meaning.
Meaning the tools of raw
survival, the sharp edges you
need in a truly wild,
unpredictable environment.
They get dulled, they atrophy.
Maybe they're even removed
metaphorically.
Because you don't need them
anymore.
If you're always fed, sheltered,
protected, you lose the need and
maybe the ability to hunt, to
defend yourself, to adapt
radically on your own.
You're safer, yes.
But less capable.
Less.
Resilient, perhaps, Less capable
of standing truly alone, of
radical self-reliance, Less able
to make that unpredictable,
untamed impact that might upset
the curated order.
It's a choice, the article
suggests, to be domesticated.
Gently, maybe, but domesticated
nonetheless.
That's a stark way to put it.
Does the article acknowledge
that maybe being freed from that
constant survival struggle
allows for other things like
creativity, innovation?
That's a really good point.
The article does acknowledge the
benefits longer life comfort,
but its main focus is definitely
on the cost to that individual
wildness, that resilience.
So it doesn't really explore the
potential upside of safety
enabling, say, art or science.
Not explicitly, no.
It leans more into prompting
you, the listener, to question
if those comforts are worth the
potential loss of those core
capacities, the claws and teeth.
The underlying vibe is that
while a comfy cage might allow
new activities, it risks losing
the primal spark that makes life
maybe truly meaningful or free.
OK, so we had the good zoo.
California is the example, but
there's the contrast places like
South Carolina, shaped by what
the article calls an older
impulse.
What does that?
Look like it's a very different
picture, almost visceral.
These are places where quote the
edge of the forest still feels
close.
Life expectancy might be lower,
violent stats higher as the meme
suggested.
Right, but the article digs into
the culture behind that.
It highlights things like the
bear gun or the revolver, not
just as tools or hobbies.
Symbols.
More than symbols as tangible
reminders that the fence is not
inevitable, it points to a
mindset where self-reliance,
personal defense, accepting
danger, it's not just tolerated,
it's woven into life, not
outsourced to some external
system.
A different relationship with
risk then.
Fundamentally different, and
with personal responsibility
too.
So living in one of these free
states shaped by this older
impulse, what does it really
mean day-to-day?
What are people accepting?
What's the belief?
It means consciously accepting
that life might be, yeah,
shorter, colder, less
predictable.
There's no promise of total
safety.
But it's not just about being
fatalistic.
No, it's coupled with the strong
belief that there is something
worth preserving in the raw.
Freedom to stand alone when you
must.
Valuing autonomy,
self-sufficiency, independent
action, even if it costs more
personally, even if it's more
dangerous.
Ruggedness over comfort.
That's a good way to put it.
And the article says this isn't
just South Carolina, it's a
broader cultural belt, Texas,
Montana, the Dakotas.
But it stresses.
It's not just geography.
Right.
Crucially, it's a cultural
mindset.
You can find free enclaves in
blue States and curated enclaves
in red states.
It's a choice people or
communities make, not just a
state line thing.
And this connects to some really
core American ideas, doesn't it?
That self-reliance thing like
don't tread on me or even
constitutional carry.
Absolutely direct lines don't
tread on me.
That's pure assertion of
individual sovereignty.
Resistance to external control.
Been around since the revolution
but still potent.
And constitutional carry.
That embodies the belief that
self-defense is an inherent
right and an individual
responsibility, not something
the state grants or restricts.
These aren't just policies,
their philosophical statements.
Drawing a line in the dust.
Exactly.
Asserting that offense, whether
it's legal or social, will not
hold if we decide to walk.
It's a powerful statement of
self determination, A
willingness to face danger on
your own terms.
The frontier spirit still
kicking.
It's a really compelling
framework, this live free or
zoo, and the article does
something fascinating.
It connects this American
tension to a classic European
film.
Yeah, shifting gears to Jean Luc
Godard and his 1965 film
Alphaville.
Goddard a Giant is a French New
Wave known for experimental
critical films.
A master of cinematic rebellion
and Alphaville is pure Goddard.
It's this weird, unsettling mix
of sci-fi and gritty film noir
detective story.
OK, what's the setup?
It's set in this dystopian city
Alphaville, run not by people
but by a sentient supercomputer,
A60.
An AI ruler.
Pretty much.
And it's logic, it's order is
absolute, it dictates
everything.
And in doing so, it eliminates
poetry, contradiction,
unpredictability, anything messy
or human.
So a perfectly logical society
becomes.
Perfectly inhuman.
That's the argument.
Rational control, efficiency,
Scientific order.
They've totally crushed emotion
and spontaneity.
Chilling.
And what's life like for the
citizens under A60, behind those
locked doors and surveillance
corridor?
Chilling.
Suffocating.
The article mentions this
constant code humming
everywhere.
Occupy, Occupy.
Libra.
Occupied.
But libre doesn't mean free.
No, that's the cruel twist.
It just means vacant, an empty
slot in the machine's grid, like
an available interrogation room.
It's a mockery of freedom,
conditional a dead end, always
within the system's rules.
And the people.
Stripped of emotion, words like
love or pity are banned.
Express them.
You're executed.
Memory is erased.
History rewritten by the
computer.
Art is gone.
So the only real freedom is.
According to the articles
interpretation, it must come
from the wild mind that refused.
This is the corridor all
together, the mind that brings
its own metaphorical claws, its
revolver, its outlaw poetry back
into the darkness outside the
fence.
Which brings us to Lemmy
Caution, Goddard's detective
protagonist.
He's that wild spark.
He is.
He's from the outer nations,
beyond the computer's control.
He slips into Alpha Ville.
A smuggler.
Yeah, but is smuggling more than
goods?
He has a revolver, Sure, symbol
of defense, but more
importantly, he carried scraps
of poetry.
Illogical thoughts, emotions,
memories, things A60 just cannot
compute.
Things that defy the algorithm.
Exactly.
He challenges people to remember
feelings, question the system.
His very presence is a reminder
that no fence is perfect, that
some animals, some people, will
always claw at the door marked
libre and.
That the price of comfort.
Is always teeth meaning real
freedom demands that sharpness,
that willingness to confront
danger, maybe even be dangerous,
the very thing the curated
system tries to to eliminate for
safety.
Now this wasn't just sci-fi
fantasy for Gedard, he was
making a point about his own
time right post war France.
Absolutely.
It was a direct critique, a
warning.
France had come through the
horrors of war, occupation,
deprivation, terror and hunger.
And then came the boom years.
The Trumpsa glorioses the 30
glorious years, unprecedented
prosperity, modernization, this
huge belief in rational
planning, technocracy, building
infrastructure, consumer
society, growing the dream of
fixing everything with logic and
efficiency.
And Goddard saw a danger in
that.
He worried that in chasing
comfort order technology, France
was losing something vital,
something human.
His warning was a zoo, no matter
how gentle its keepers, is still
a cage if you lose the memory of
the woods outside.
And the whole French New Wave
movement was part of that
critique, reacting against
commercial American films, sure,
but also questioning France's
own technocratic shift,
critiquing state power, mass
media, the way life was being
contained, industrialized even,
in a prosperous society.
That's such a powerful link, a
60s French film speaking to this
core American tension.
And the article makes another
connection to a huge American
symbol, also a gift from France.
It's a really smart parallel, it
points out.
It's no accident that France
gave America the Statue of
Liberty and not the Statue of
Perfect Safety.
Good point.
They didn't send a guarantee of
care.
No, they sent a flame, a torch
against the wind.
The article calls it a dare
rather than a guarantee.
A challenge, not a promise of
comfort.
It demands something from us.
And we often think of the poem
Give me your tired, your poor.
But the source points out that's
not original.
Right.
That famous Emma Lazarus poem
was an American edition put on
the pedestal years later.
Important, yes, but not part of
the original French gift.
So the original intent was
different.
More about revolutionary
liberty, that universal
struggle.
The American edition, beautiful
as it is, shifts it towards
freedom as refuge, a haven, the
source emphasizes.
The core message was maybe
closer to keep this flame if you
can stay wild enough to need it.
A call to maintain that spirit
of independence resilience.
Yeah, an active participation in
Freedom's Wager, not just
relying on safety Nets.
So if Lady of Liberty is this
dare, how does America's history
with actual wilderness fit in?
Our geography must have shaped
this tension.
Hugely, the article argues,
America didn't inherit like neat
British garden walls or rigid
class hierarchy.
It inherited that French
instinct that freedom is a
brutal wager, that it's risky,
not guaranteed.
And the early settlers, The
Puritans.
They fear the wilderness, the
source says.
More than any native tribe.
They saw the endless forest as a
moral abyss.
Why?
No fences, no kings, no keepers,
no hedge against failure.
Terrifying.
A lack of order.
Exactly.
A place of disorder, Temptation.
No social control.
It's paradoxical, right?
They sought freedom from old
rules, but we're terrified of a
world without rules.
But that fear was crucial.
Yeah, because it forced this
reckoning with true
self-reliance, having to build
internal discipline when
external structures were gone.
They had to build their own
fences, Literal and Oracle.
And out of that fear, that
confrontation with the wild,
came the rugged individualist.
Yes, out of that abyss grew the
frontier mind, that core
American archetype, the rugged
individualist who does not exist
without risk, forged by
self-reliance, where survival
wasn't guaranteed by society.
And the article connected to
specific ideas and figures.
Right Emerson.
Self-reliance, Trust yourself,
avoid conformity.
Turner's Frontier thesis.
How the frontier shaped American
democracy.
Individualism, innovation, and
figures like the Texas Ranger.
The cattlemen.
Symbols of independence in the
wild.
And bringing it to today.
It links directly back to things
like the constitutional carry
states still drawing that line
in the dust, saying a fence will
not hold if we decide to walk.
It's not just about guns.
It's asserting sovereignty,
rejecting that ultimate security
comes from external.
Rules so live free or die,
spirit.
Exactly.
Freedom means risk safety bought
with submission.
Isn't freedom a direct challenge
to the perfectly curated risk
free idea?
Liberty demands that constant
wager.
It's so clear this tension isn't
just politics or history.
It echoes through culture, right
in literature and metaphors of
confinement.
We might not even notice.
Absolutely.
The article uses some really
poignant examples.
The caged bird sings not because
it is content, but because it's
song is the only thing the bars
cannot reach.
So the song is Defiance, a
reminder of freedom.
Exactly.
Not happiness in the cage, but
the spirit finding its only
outlet.
And then there's the mad woman
in the attic.
Trope from Jane Eyre.
Famously, yeah.
Perfectly kept, well fed, well
watched, safe from the cold, but
never free to run into the woods
that would have probably kill
her sooner than her padded cell.
Another paradox, Safety that
extinguishes life's essence.
That's the point.
Secure confinement, even if it
prolongs life, can kill the
spark of authentic selfhood, the
article stresses.
There are truths in feminism,
literature and American myth
that all circle back to the same
idea.
The wilderness is not safe.
That is exactly why it matters.
Meaning is found in the
challenge in the Untamed.
That's the implication in those
spaces, physical or
metaphorical, where true self
definition, potential for
greatness or failure really
exists.
These stories remind us of the
human cost of too much safety.
Which brings us back to that
meme.
Don't California my South
Carolina, the article points out
a big irony in how people move
today related to this zoo idea.
It's a fascinating irony.
It says California's better zoo
is real.
Its gates are soft enough that
most who leave end up rebuilding
them elsewhere.
Meaning people leave the zoo but
take it with them.
That's the suggestion.
People who loudly say don't
California, my South Carolina.
They often flee the zoo only to
carry it with them.
They move to Austin, Boise,
Montana, seeking something
different.
Lower costs, maybe a more rugged
feel.
But they often bring the same
underlying desires for safety,
regulation, amenities, comfort
that define the place they left.
They might complain about
traffic, but they implicitly
demand the services and
structures that create that
curated life.
So the fence just expands.
It rebuilds itself elsewhere.
Exactly.
Article describes how this
expanding fence happens.
Not suddenly.
The gate becomes a state line,
then a city ordinance, then a
homeowners association, then a
culture that says we would
rather be safe curated.
Well, Fed, it's incremental,
chosen bit by bit.
Yes, the subtle spread of the
zoo impulse driven by individual
choices, prioritizing
predictability, comfort like
strict HOA rules and new
developments or demanding more
city services in growing towns.
Each step reduces friction risk,
increases comfort.
And the end result.
The chilling conclusion the
article draws is and one day,
the corridor that hums occupy is
all that remains back to Alpha
Ville, where even the illusion
of choice fades into an ordered
but empty existence.
That's yeah of sobering thought,
this gradual chosen confinement.
The article also distinguishes
between types of zoos, doesn't
it?
Hard cages versus soft cages.
Yes, and it's an important
distinction.
It helps us see the spectrum of
control.
The crude prison industrial
complex, that's the hard cage
version.
Obvious physical confinement.
Visible bars force clear.
Restriction and the soft
version.
Modern zoo Urban planning is the
soft version.
Thanks.
Cities, suburbs, communities
designed for comfort convene
safety.
These lead to longer lifespans,
more gentle curators, better
toys, and easier life.
But they're still cages.
Still fences, the article
argues, Often invisible.
These invisible fences are the
web of regulations, social
norms, conformity pressures,
dependencies on systems that
subtly limit radical freedom in
exchange for security.
It's control without obvious
force.
Exactly, you're not forced into
the cage, you're just given
every reason to want to stay
inside it's comfortable walls.
Wow.
OK, so we've gone from a meme to
state contrast to Goddard's
Alphaville to American history,
to cultural echoes.
It all seems to circle back to
this one fundamental choice
right for individuals, for
society.
Absolutely.
The whole deep dive really lands
on that core decision.
Live free or zoo.
Safety and comfort look great on
paper.
Longer lives, less risk.
But there's that vital wild
spark that only comes from
embracing risk, the unknown.
And accepting the potential
downsides.
Yeah, the article acknowledges
the frontier mind accepts that
some people will die younger,
hungry or more violently, that
they won't measure up on some
accountants spreadsheet of
safety.
Yet yet they keep the
metaphorical bear gun the
unlocked door.
Right.
They will keep the bear gun, the
revolver, the door marked libre
that you cannot lock no matter
how strong the fence becomes.
It's holding on to that internal
wilderness, refusing to be fully
tamed, even if it's harder.
And like in Alphaville, the
guardians, the zookeepers, they
don't actually kill that spark
directly.
It's a choice people make
themselves.
That's Goddard's really
unsettling insight.
Yeah, A60 didn't crush freedom
by force.
The film suggests the animals do
it themselves when they choose
the warmth of the cage over the
cold wind outside.
And internal surrender, Choosing
comfort over liberty.
Exactly.
The real threat isn't the bars,
maybe, but the will to climb
them fading away.
So where does this leave us?
You, the listener, thinking
about our own choices, our
society's direction.
It means that flame in the
harbor, Lady Liberty.
Maybe it stands for nothing if
we forget what it means to stand
under it without a keeper,
without that guarantee of
perfect safety.
It's a call for personal
responsibility, resilience.
And a reminder of what real
freedom demands.
It can be brutal.
The article ends with this
really powerful line echoing
Goddard and American history.
Liberty, equality and
brotherhood belong to the
wilderness, not the pen.
Wow.
That's something to chew on.
It really is a challenge,
challenges you to ask.
Is the comfort we seek leading
us into a gilded cage?
Is that wildness inside still
strong enough to want the dorm
marked Libre truly free?
Have we forgotten the woods
outside the fence?
A question for all of us.